da hat sich tatsächlich jemand einfach
am pc in einen redstone blog gebaut
also er hat ersten redstone burg gebaut
und dann im pc da rein ich kann euch
jetzt mal bild einblenden genau dann
checkt man da mal geschafft und jetzt
die kamera servus skills und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in dem
wir heute eine runde league spielen
werde und ich werde von zwei dingen
erzählen die richtig coolen interessant
sind und zwar kann ich euch heute mal
ganz kurz oder eventuell etwas länger je
nachdem was die runde so hergibt blöcke
sind geil aus meine neue kamera
vorstellen
ich hab mir nämlich eine neue kamera für
die loks zugelegt und gerne auch mal
eure meinung dazu hören die kann man
theoretisch auch noch umtauschen
ich erkläre es gleich warum ich mich für
genau die entschieden habt ihr gefällt
mir richtig gut
ihr könnt auch gerne sagen falls ihr die
schon mal hatte tweedy so ist ich habe
die bisher noch nicht ausprobiert ich
werde sehr wahrscheinlich wollte
ausprobieren ich fühle mich heute nacht
eigentlich diese blöcke junge die sind
richtig geil aus ich hatte mich heute
nach köln zu max der momentan auch
gerade in köln ist und wir drehen morgen
eine kleinigkeit aber was ist eine
kleinigkeit eigentlichen groß sich kite
falls ich das wort euch ein begriff ist
eine richtig coole sache und ich möchte
gern die reise dahin so ein bisschen wie
locken und dann die an kunden vielleicht
auch den abend und das gerne morgen
hochladen
vielleicht machen wir ein kleines wer
bin ich oder so könnte mir auch gut
vorstellen falls ihr darauf bock gehabt
schreibt gerne in die kommentare ich auf
jeden fall richtig ich habe mich so
gefreut hätte ich wie eine kamera zu
haben leute hier wissen wie das war ich
habe ja lange geschichte die lega in
berlin liegen lassen für mcdonald's
gedreht und dann gab's mega stress wegen
der abreise weil wir so spät dran waren
die hatten irgendwie den dreh bisschen
verplant und dann hieß es so ja okay wir
fahren jetzt sofort ab jetzt sofort wenn
wir innerhalb von 20 sekunden im wenn
und in der hektik habe ich wohl meine
kamera liegen lassen
als 20 sekunden hatte ich keine lüge es
war unfassbar gehetzt ja dass das kleine
background info aber ja ich habe mir die
moment mal
dsc wx5 100 von sony zugelegt
kompakte digitalkamera die kann ich euch
rechne man die kern halten und dazu noch
so ein kleines ärmchen in arm / tripod
so ein kombiniertes teil das finde ich
richtig cool
die hatten es leider nicht so in den
topf farben aber ich denke es einfach
cool style
das kann man gleichzeitig nicht
gleichzeitig aber es kann man sowohl
dazu benutzten die kamera zu halten
bisschen weiter weg zu halten als am arm
weil das ist keine weit weg kamera
das heißt wenn man die bisschen weiter
weg hält dürfte das durchaus von vorteil
sein so und andererseits kann man das
eben als stativ benutzen kann man nach
lust und laune verbiegen also gerade so
wie man es braucht für den job den man
gerade vor hat deswegen dachte ich mir
dass wir eine ganz gute sache vielleicht
mache ich erstmal hier kann auf dem chip
man fertig dann habe ich es mal kurz
rein und dann können wir nachher noch
auf die zweite satz zu sprechen kommt
und zwar ist es ein minecraft pcs hat
sich tatsächlich jemand einfach einen pc
in einem minecraft blog gebaut und
redstone pc der sind die richtig richtig
cool aus wenn wir gleich darüber reden
kann ich erst mal ein bild an blenden so
genau den check man da mal geschafft und
jetzt die kamera so seht ihr aus zack
macht ihr mal kurz an fuhr ich hier raus
jetzt gedrückt weil ich das mache ich
gerade keine speicherkarte ja gut zu
wissen vielfach kommen hier den display
so hochklappen und der trick ist ich
habe mir noch diesen tripod arm dazu
bestellt ist kann die kamera kann man
hier oben so drauf stellen und sich dann
super selbst damit film ist er richtig
coole sache also wie gesagt wenn jemand
von euch erfahrung mit der dsc wx5 100
hat gerne gerne gerne in die kommentare
wird mich interessieren noch kann man
die kamera theoretisch und tauschen
falls die in irgendeiner hinsicht total
schlecht sein sollte ich hoffe mal dass
der ton klar geht das wird sich aber
erst zeigen wenn ich damit man wieder
geschossen hat super gefallen
jetzt kommt es noch nicht sagen wir
probieren es einfach mal aus so ich wäre
heute bisschen wie logan und dann gucken
wir mal wie das will ich habe mir dazu
noch eine 64 gigabyte speicherkarte
geholt als es doch genug platz drauf ich
habe ehrlich gesagt bisschen gestützt
als ich mir da die formate durchgeschaut
habe und die formate einstellen sollte
sie wider so die wildesten bezeichnung
für die avc hd format also man kann ja
in mp4 aufnehmen da kennt massa mit
einer standheizung 1080p 25 frames aber
immer ein avc hd einstellt hatte ich ja
durch den piloten
wenn man ein abo cad einstellt dann
steht da sowas wie keine ahnung 27 mp fx
und sowas hat gar keinen plan was es ist
muss ich dann erst mal nachschauen
abläufen format gefunden was ungefähr
1080p 50 fps gleichkommt sodann kann
wahrscheinlich dass in 50 fps hochladen
ob ich auf 30 runter renderer wobei das
glaube ich keine gute idee ist das
können wir auch mal die kommentare
schreiben
ist es irgendwie in irgendeiner art und
weise schlecht für das bild wenn man es
von 50 auf 30 fps verändert ich könnte
mir nämlich sehr gut vorstellen dass der
übrigen käse passiert deswegen lieber
mal vor schon mal vorab checken so ok
und genau erfahrung habe ich schon
gesagt gerne in die kommentare so und
war weiter ja genau das ist so tricky
diese ändert sich versteckte jedes mal
aber diesmal ich die gesehen hat
da hast du nicht gedacht play meinte du
alter trick wo die zweite sache die wir
noch ansprechen wollte dieser minecraft
pc dass da bin ich gerade drauf gestoßen
ist nicht richtig cool
da hat sich tatsächlich jemand einfach
am pc in einen redstone blog gebaut
also er hat ersten redstone blog gebaut
und dann im pc da rein ich kann euch
jetzt mal bild einblenden
so sieht das aus schon ganz witzig das
teil also komplett selbst gebaut das
kommt mit freaky und hat auch maus und
tastatur und alles andere so außenrum
selbst in minecraft sie gebaut dazu noch
mal hier im bild und dass das coolste
ist er hat dazu auch noch eine anleitung
hochgeladen also für alle von euch diese
richtige tag heads sind die bock hätten
das mal auszuprobieren kann ich euch
auch den link zur bauanleitung mal in
die beschreibung packen ist auf jeden
fall eine ganz witzige sache würde ich
sagen also sieht richtig cool aus wenn
man die kommentare schreiben was er
davon halte das ist eine sinnlose
spielerei oder lohnt sich das
da seine zeit daran zu investieren weil
der alte man sieht aber dass glas
überhaupt nicht mehr 3d
naja das ist noch so ein ding so offene
glas pains die nicht mit dem blog
connect sind sieht man durch bisschen
schlecht meine ich mir ein zu bilden
ich hoffe wir können noch unsere schwert
in scheint man hat immer so ein bisschen
in job und back aber wir haben
theoretisch ein level durch das durch
das buch das gibt uns einen level und
wir haben auch eigentlich den entfernt
so also sollte dem eigentlich nichts im
weg stehen
ich glaube so geht das ja heute hat man
hat das einfach gerade überhaupt nicht
gesehen
jetzt muss man hier außenrum sprengen
nicht euer ernst
wie man sich die glasbrücke einfach
überhaupt nicht als ob wir was ist
erhält man sieht die glasbrücke
überhaupt nicht krass okay da hat die
kraft auf jeden fall eine krasse
schwäche ja erläutert petra der ist
übrigens das texture pack verliert es
nicht wussten ob jetzt nochmal sekunden
würde ich mal sagen wir nutzen die zeit
um so ein bisschen zu in krippen
entscheiden würde ich mir machen wartet
so glaube ich mal kurz um die ecke da
könne mal gucken ob wir zeit haben das
den leuten es packt einfach wieder junge
es nervt einfach so hat diese
entscheiden packt man voll ärgerlich
egal er muss ja so kämpfen
immerhin haben eine angel da kann ich
wieder meine nicht vorhandenen apps
demonstrieren
zack mal hier runter auf dem erba
downstairs so und den hut in den ring zu
vorne sagte tietmeyer sorgt laut nolte
was ist das für eine combo deal alter
für diese gomopa dem sie fucking kills
die leistung richtig neu ist hier auf
jeden fall hätte ich mir schon geholt
ok damit dass man kurze runde so der
winzer hat unbedingt haben es geht der
takt wieder los training vielleicht in
den anderen reihen wussten ja zwei mal
wieder erwischt
ja es wird von einer wirklich so so kurz
liefen aber alles machen wirklich eine
richtig coole sache ich habe die kamera
können schon einiges bewegen
das werden wir aber sehen morgen als ich
werde heute filmen dann max hat gemeinde
gutes hotel internet in dem hotel wo er
gerade ist dann lade ich das einfach
ganz flugs bei ihm hoch müsste ich
glaube hat 25 mb upload im hotel also
das habe ich so was habe ich noch nie
gehört dass jemand 1 25er upload im
hotel hat wie sie einfach team habe das
gesehen teams verboten
justin nur bei ich kann dich angegriffen
habt wollte nur kurz sagen so ja genau
kommen jetzt team gegen mich ob gott
jungs richtig dreckig wie ich will
lieber sie glauben sie einfach nicht an
habt ihr es gesehen
straight teamleiter sie wussten sich
auch noch mit den jungs hat ja irgendwie
legastheniker da unten steht auch
teaming ist verbinden ihn als jetzt wie
alt ich schwöre also okay egal wir
müssen gucken wie wir die holen nehme
auf jetzt player ist aber ich
konzentriere mich jetzt mal kurz
soweit alles abgehakt was ich heute
ansprechen wollte zum thema camera hell
wie hadi am team sind das ist so frech
kommt
die wollen mich doch mal ne riesen alter
ich hab jetzt erst mal dem anderen
also nicht im team gesehen sondern
einfach in die ferne wieder herzustellen
weil ihr aufgeben wenn wir dann gleich
nice aber erst wenn man schon mal dauern
jan hinter mir ja klar da wo ich mal
auch zack gehen wir über zudem soll er
hat sich dennoch geholt
der fußgänger lies er ist auch dann
hatte er irgendwas cooles mit here now
fakt ist verschwunden
jetzt kommt er an den brauch ich habe
auch noch so okay jetzt haben wir schon
mal mit ja junge als ob du dir jetzt
voraus wollt ich glaube es nicht
rohletter neben ok dauern aber sollte
klappen
wo hat er noch drei leben egal im moment
so usa wo bist du
war wohl nix mit team also für jeden
fall erstmal saftig gebannt würde ich
sagen er ist einfach noch in deutschland
ist niemand kann man dort sehr schön
daun mit sieben herzen das passt
eigentlich ja den job muss auf jeden
fall holen
ich würde mich jetzt nicht so weit aus
dem fenster lehnen zu sagen dass wir
jetzt schon said gewonnen haben aber es
sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus ist eine
maus spiel oder eine maus spiel
algorithmus kokoro ok am 6 herzen den
papa will ich sagen nein
doch first hat noch mal okay denn jetzt
noch 19 doch nicht immer noch nicht wie
viel das ist alter und neuer zu viel
fressen gras die sehr schöne runde hat
mir gut gefallen also schreibt gern noch
mal eure meinung zur kamera und zu
diesen minecraft pcr ein eigentlich ganz
neiße sacken wir sehen uns